good afternoon
it's wonderful to be with you today
and thank you dr clayton and your
colleagues at the office of research on
women's health for the invitation to
join this extremely important session
it's a real honor for me
in fact it's personal
nih has been part of my career from the
get-go
my first paycheck
after graduate school
came through an
nih-sponsored clinical trial the largest
one ever at the time
the multiple risk factor intervention
trial commonly known as mr fit
now
i was the project director for the san
francisco project site
and one of the things i was responsible
for was recruitment
we recruited men only men
to participate in this
primary prevention trial on
cardiovascular disease
and we trained recruiters to explain to
men and women that everything that would
be discovered
about preventing heart disease in men
would of course
apply to women too
now that strikes
everyone i talked to today and actually
people at the time
as just nuts doesn't make any sense at
all and it didn't make sense and yet
it was the scientific consensus of the
day
science changes all the time
it's one of the challenges we have right
now in talking about what we know and
what we don't know yet
about the pandemic and about vaccines
and about so much
that ails people
science is now
and science will be tomorrow i'm pretty
excited to have been part
of the nih journey if you will for a
very long time now
and i'm proud of the fact that i've been
part of it as nih has repeatedly met the
moment
right now meeting the moment means
overcoming the pandemic
and avoiding preventing the next one
but it also means improving the
recognition and support and trust in
science
that we hear so much about today and i
will be talking about that in my remarks
but first a little more about the moment
30 years ago when nih stepped up
30 years ago we were at a pivot point in
our nation's failure to recognize the
importance of women's health and women's
health research
the urgent focus wasn't brought in
ultimate change wasn't brought on by a
pandemic of course but by women's health
advocates
who urged women leaders in particular
in congress to demand change
and they did
they brought about enormous progress
which has been carried on over the years
through leaders like dr clayton and
starting with the first director
of the office of what is now called the
office of research on women's health my
friend vivian in
in the congress a bipartisan group of
women
who included
congresswoman marella
senator snow she was congresswoman at
the time senator um congresswoman
schroeder and the ringleader senator
barbara mikulski
here you see
senator mikulski
as she is received making remarks on
receiving an award from research america
a few years ago and she recalled the
days when uh it was ten thousand male
medical students
who were testing the famous take an
aspirin a day keep a heart attack away
she was pretty riled up known for being
riled up and forgetting results
and she along with her colleagues
marched out to the nih they actually
took a taxi
and
had a meeting with then director
bernadine healey
change started happening
others lots of others were involved in
meeting that moment i am really proud of
the fact that i was there
urging folks on at the time as well
there were groups like the society for
women's health research with its
renowned founder
florence hazeltine
one of the greats of nih's robust
history
of leadership
and
i already mentioned dr vivian penn
this office and nih overall has
accomplished so much to be proud of over
the last 30 years but we all know
there's much more challenge out there
when you think about
the appalling level of maternal maternal
mortality in this country especially
among women of color there's so much
more that we need to understand and then
put into action
[Music]
sadly there's still
a very high level
of harassment sexual harassment
across the research community
and
that needs to end progress is great but
it needs to stop
and last but not least in my book of the
incredible importance of overcoming
challenges to diversity
and inclusion
in our in our society overall but
including in the scientific community
and in health care
so there are many those and many many
more challenges so thank god we have the
office for research of women's health
i want to talk about research america
for just a moment
we were formed in 1989
to meet the moment it was a time that
the congress
was
not as strong as it had been previously
in
funding nih and in doing everything
within its power to assure
that nih
and and industry working hand in hand
would meet the moment and find the
solutions to what ails us
so a group of individuals
that included jack whitehead who had
also founded the whitehead institute at
mit
and ted cooper who had for so long been
the leader of then national institutes
of health excuse me the national heart
institute
they and others came together to form
research america and it remains to this
day a robust alliance of stakeholders
across the
community from academia industry
patient groups and non-profits
scientific societies and foundations in
various state and local
organizations we act together we speak
with one voice advocacy is about many
voices with a shared message
driving for change
meeting the moment
the ways we work are i think familiar to
many of you and they're not unique to
research america
again the best advocacy
is in alliance with many many others
many voices making the case one of the
things we do and have for a long time is
commissioned public opinion surveys and
i'll talk about that in a minute but i
want to underscore the point about
partnerships and alliances whether it's
with the public and private sectors
working together we have examples right
now like operation warp speed
or whether it's about
public and private with patient
communities
very much engaged that didn't used to be
the case it certainly wasn't 30 years
ago but it's
the state of the art now and thank
goodness because that will help power
research
going forward to have the patient's
voice at the table from the get-go
my friend don berwick wrote a powerful
essay in jama back in june seems like a
million years ago just june though
about meeting the moment and he talked
about the new normal
and about taking a role personally and
as a leader
in assuring that what comes next is
about choices we make now the right
choices it really resonated for me and i
hope for you as you think about your
role as leaders and you all are
what kind of choices am i talking about
certainly choices to make sure that
women's voices are at the table
and that women's health research
is a robust vital component of the nih
agenda but there's many other choices
those we make every day
and those that we make to assure that
voices that haven't been heard
will be heard now we're at a tipping
point in so many respects in our nation
right now and all of us all of you
have choices to make now that are going
to make a big difference for hundreds
thousands hundreds of thousands of
people going forward
i mentioned public opinion survey data
we know from a very recent survey we
commissioned that was in august of this
year
that we're now in the level of art of
urgency not just important but we're now
at a level of urgency
in terms of public demand
that we place a higher priority on
science in this nation now you can see
here that that's a bipartisan demand
across parties and independents
based on what we've been experiencing
living through
with horror
the pandemic that has taken so many
lives and caused disruption
and has implications that we're going to
see
lasting for years and years to come
it's time to put science to work at the
level it can deliver
public sentiment which i just referred
to there
is what we're talking about and that's
what
decision makers ultimately are
responsible to public sentiment to the
voter
to advocates who speak up exercising
their constitutional right to be heard
to petition the government
abraham lincoln said this best i think
that public sentiment is frankly
everything without it nothing can
succeed and that's the reason
that we have for many years now been
commissioning public opinion surveys to
help our members to help us to help
every advocate
to know what's on the minds of the
american public the good news the bad
news the messaging that works and that
that's confusing
or undercuts trust what it's intended to
sustain it
so our methodology
that of our vendors i should say because
we don't actually conduct surveys we
commission them but our methodology is
the same as those others use whether it
be pew or kaiser or gallup or any number
of others
not all the news is good in these
surveys
we see and you've seen it elsewhere and
heard a lot of coverage and probably
have a lot of concern
about declining belief in the benefit of
vaccines and hesitancy in saying whether
one would take for example a covid
vaccine
personally
i believe that we're going to see a
surge in demand among people who want
this vaccine they've had enough
of death and illness in their own
families and their communities
but we shall see time will tell there's
been a trend over the last several years
of declining belief in the value of
vaccines that's a very serious challenge
for the science community because
vaccines without vaccinations aren't
going to help
it's time for all of us to
take time to be a leader to be a clear
voice on the value of vaccines
now i talked about urgency earlier
we asked in this survey back in august
about
20 or so issues and ask people to rank
them in terms of the priority level for
the nation
now i'm just showing you the top six
responses
obviously and expectedly uh as we
expected ending the pandemic came in
number one but it was essentially the
same
in the same rank order as finding new
ways of preventing treating and curing
other illnesses
and although we've combined urgent and
high priority here i'm here to tell you
that urgent is over 50 percent
urgent that's mandate language that's
pay attention decision makers do more to
help us in the research community in the
innovation community
achieve medical progress
we also asked and you see that in the
red bar whether people felt that science
could help
in achieving the answers finding the
solutions in each of these areas
and the percent that said science can
help a lot is also shown here
so there isn't any question despite what
you
may suspect or have heard elsewhere
the public the american public continues
to support science let me talk about
that a little more
this is pew data
and it shows early in the pandemic this
is april the most recent data here is
april of 2020
that u.s adults say they have a great
deal and you can see that rising great
deal of confidence
in scientists and medical scientists in
particular to act in the best interests
of the public this far eclipses the
other groups shown here and actually
it's been true for many years it's just
we're seeing a surge or pew recorded a
surge
just since the pandemic began
we saw this too
in that august survey and you can see
here nurses doctors and scientists
coming in at the top
in terms of same kind of question
confidence
to act in your best interest
that's really what it's all about acting
in the best interests of the public
serving the public's interest that's
what you do that's what we do
that's what all of our partners do
together and articulating that living it
breathing it
is is what meeting the moment right now
is all about
now my hypothesis
which there's some data on at least is
that even as trust in institutions is
steadily declining and that's true
in data from many organizations
still trust in individuals is increasing
and i think because of this
it's the individuals who are going to
lend credibility and increase trust
to institutions
it means putting a human face on the
institution
literally
making sure that when we show
and talk about institutions we're not
looking at buildings but we're looking
at people
because it's the people
who are the conveyors the purveyors of
trust and confidence
now
it's we've learned over the years that
a shockingly low percentage of the
public
can't name a living scientist by this i
mean that science is essentially
invisible
to the public we've got to change this
now there's been some good news and
thank you tony fauci for driving that
we see we've seen an increase
you can see here who people do name when
they say they can name a living
scientist
and this is let's
underscore it august of this past year
this same year
but the shocking to me thing is that 71
of americans don't even try they don't
even guess they don't name someone who's
dead albert einstein stephen hawking
they don't they just say no i can't name
a living scientist
despite the fact that
someone who might be a scientist
but never self-identified
could be living in their neighborhood
have a child in the same school or play
group
there's a lot of ways that scientists
end up hiding out when we should be much
more prominent
now the news is also not great
when people are asked to name a place
any place where medical or health
research is conducted this is not a hard
question now this is pre-pandemic
question and we will be asking it again
next month in january 2021 and i hope
we'll see
another surge there was previously
quite an increase
from 35 percent to 53 over a couple of
year period
i don't know exactly why that was but
we're going to see whether it holds up
and even strengthens going forward
but still this is shocking
that only about half of americans can
name anywhere that research is conducted
again i underscore the point it's
invisible too invisible
and finally in this series of
invisibility
the unfortunate reality is that
two-thirds of americans don't know
that medical research in the u.s is
conducted in all 50 states they don't
know
that it's right there at their state
university they don't know that it's
right there at the medical center in
their in the closest city
that's a problem one that we need to
overcome and can overcome if we set our
minds to it we can change these metrics
and with it we can put a more more human
faces
on the conduct of science it's the
people who are going to derive this
and assure that we maintain the public's
trust
so i want to charge you to think about
what you're going to do to meet the
moment in the months and years ahead to
increase the visibility of science you
can do that by telling your story you
can do that by listening you can do that
by inviting conversations including
those about skepticism after all
scientists are trained to be skeptical
so why should we be critical
of members of the non-science public to
express skepticism it's a good thing to
ask why
or can i really trust what you just said
or tell me more
encourage skepticism meet people where
they are say we have that in common
being skeptics you're thinking like a
scientist
i do think that we need to modernize the
relationship between scientists and the
public
i think it would be a healthy thing
if every graduate science student
learned in a systematic way not just at
an optional workshop that is part of the
curriculum
how to participate in public engagement
how to be an effective communicator
how to convey
trust
how to talk about certainty
and what isn't certain yet how to talk
about what we know now
and what we're going to know with your
support with public support
in the days ahead
we've made so much progress
women's health women's health research
has made so much progress people take it
for granted now that women are full
participants in studies it wasn't always
thus but it is now there's much more to
do and not only for women's health for
science broadly
science for the future of our nation
it's time for a science strong future
in the us and globally
we can get there i think a big part of
it is putting your face on research
meeting the moment personally
we like to say that the most important
four words a scientist can say and
convey convey with your attitude with
your willingness
to listen with your willingness to work
together with people
the most important four words are
i work for you
i work for you
not saying i'm a geneticist i'm a
virologist but rather saying
i work for you and let the conversation
go
where the other person wants most to
take it
it's a privilege to work for others to
serve the public's interest
i feel that privilege every day
i'm not a scientist myself but i work
for you
and so does research america
thank you so much for the opportunity to
be here today to be part of this
celebration and to be part of what comes
next under the leadership of all of you
and i say
again thank you